et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Manuel bon par bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous c'est des
Bouches-du-Rhône coordinateur de la
France insoumise on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour un interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Christelle Bertrand merci d'être
là
dépêche on va commencer en parlant de ce
qui s'est passé hier à l'Assemblée les
trois présidents de groupe de la
majorité présidentielle demande des
sanctions contre les députés présents
samedi à la manifestation interdite en
mémoire d'Adama Traoré parmi ces députés
il y avait Mathilde panos député de
votre groupe manuel Montard est-ce que
la majorité n'a pas raison de dire que
c'est un problème non je pense que la
majorité dans une grave dérive
autoritaire et considère que maintenant
on va même s'en prendre à des députés en
raison des actions qu'ils ont prises à
l'extérieur de l'hémicycle ce qui est
complètement nouveau c'est totalement
inédit et je pense que oui
manifestations n'avait aucune raison
d'être interdite c'est marche qui ont
lieu depuis 7 ans maintenant se déroule
et ce sont toujours déroulés dans le
calme je rappelle que ces démarches qui
sont organisées suite à la mort de Adama
Traoré qui est mort suite à un contrôle
de gendarmerie et sa famille demande de
savoir ce qui s'est passé demande la
vérité demande la justice et je pense
que la décision qui a été prise par les
préfets d'abord du Val d'Oise et ensuite
de Paris d'interdire cette manifestation
ce sont des décisions totalement
incompréhensibles et je pense que notre
devoir notre responsabilité c'était
d'être présent à cette manifestation
pour vérifier comment ça se passait et
puis pour soutenir le collectif qui
était à l'initiative de cette
manifestation parce que il était
légitime qu'il puisse manifester et je
ne connais pas ces sanctions non mais
d'abord elles sont elles demandent
il y a des demandes de sanction et je
mets en garde j'arrête je dis que si
dorénavant parce que des groupes de la
majorité lui demande à ce qu'on
sanctionne des députés parce qu'ils ont
participé à des manifestations je pense
qu'on va ouvrir une boîte de Pandore oui
mais puisque vous êtes des des fins
connaissances de la vie politique vous
seriez peut-être vous savez peut-être
que par exemple des députés de droite
monsieur Gosselin par exemple ont
participé à une manifestation qui était
interdite une fois devant l'Assemblée
nationale à l'époque du mariage pour
tous et que personne n'a eu pour idée de
venir les sanctionner donc je dis
attention à ces boîtes de grandeur qui
s'ouvrent berger par exemple qui est la
présidente du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée c'est que les députés ne
puissent plus manifestent participer
avec leur écharpe tricolore à toute
manifestation interdite elle pense à
Sainte Soline est-ce que une nouvelle
règle j'ai bien compris que Madame
berger voudrait maintenant pouvoir
choisir les manifestations dans lequel
les membres de l'opposition le droit
d'aller et celle où ils n'ont pas droit
d'aller mais j'informe madame berger que
en fait elle ne décide pas notre place
et que nous allons avec notre écharpe
tricolore parce que nous
nationale qui peut le décider et si le
fait
d'avoir une franchiront un cap
supplémentaire dans cette dérive
autoritaire que je dénonce et surtout il
faut qu'il s'attende à ce que nous
déposions des recours y compris auprès
de la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme qui a déjà ces dernières années
sanctionner ce qui s'était passé dans un
parlement national parce que ça ne ça ne
correspondait pas et ça ne respectait
pas notamment les règles de la
Constitution je rappelle que le droit de
manifester et garanti par notre
Constitution que la liberté d'expression
est garantie par notre Constitution et
donc c'est des droits sur lesquels on
peut pas revenir comme ça au gré des
désaccords politiques alors j'entends
mais la manifestation c'est quand même
déroulé au son de tout le monde déteste
la police là pour le coup non elle sait
pas dérouler son de tout le monde
déteste la police manifestement ce
slogan a été scandé il a été scandé par
aucun des députés de la France insoumise
vous pouvez le voir sur les images si on
circulait du slogan est-ce qu'il aurait
fallu le faire mais nous avons tous dit
que nous nous utilisions pas ce slogan
parce que il est factuellement faux tout
le monde ne déteste pas la police vous
pouvez prendre les sondages et vous
verrez que ce n'est pas le cas présent
on a envoyé un petit peu si vous voulez
il faut arrêter de de sauter à la corde
des injonctions macronistes parce que si
vous voulez maintenant qu'on fasse la
liste des manifestations dans lequel il
y a eu des slogans qui étaient des
slogans et inacceptables et dans lequel
un certain nombre de responsables de la
majorité en participé ne se sont pas des
solidarisés je peux vous par exemple
quand il y a eu une manifestation devant
l'Assemblée nationale à l'appel du
syndicat Alliance et que le syndicat
Alliance a dit le problème de la police
c'est la justice où nous allons faire
céder les digues de la Constitution qui
ont été dit à ce moment-là en présence
de Monsieur Darmanin en présence d'un
certain nombre de responsables de la
majorité je me rappelle pas qu'ils aient
quitté la manifestation pour dire qu'ils
étaient en désaccord avec ce slogan
je vous parle d'un certain nombre de
manifestations au moment du mariage pour
tous par exemple où il y a eu des propos
inacceptables et des propos homophobes
qui ont été dit dans un certain nombre
de manifestations et qu'un certain
nombre de responsables qui sont
aujourd'hui au gouvernement étaient dans
ces manifestations elles n'ont pas
quitté on peut en parler aussi donc je
dis attention parce que si vous
commencez à rentrer dans cette dans
cette voie là bah alors ça va ouvrir une
boîte de Pandore et on s'en sortira
jamais
Darmanin a rendu hommage au policiers
qui sont morts en service vous avez
refusé de vous lever contrairement
les députés de la France insoumise se
sont levés non c'est pas vrai parce que
Monsieur Darmanin n'a pas dû n'a pas
rendu hommage
l'impression que vous avez un problème
avec la police alors je vois vous avez
refusé de vous lever d'abord je vais
répondre sur la police mais ce n'est pas
vrai parce que Monsieur Darmanin s'est
livré à une nouvelle récupération et
instrumentalisation audience je dis
nouvelle parce que c'est pas la première
fois qu'il le fait parce que Madame
berger l'a déjà fait à plusieurs
reprises la dernière fois la semaine
dernière madame Berger a expliqué que ce
pompier auquel je rends hommage qui
obsédé l'avait été dans un lien avec les
révoltes alors que tout le monde dit que
ce n'avait il y avait aucun rapport
entre les deux donc ce type de
récupération est totalement inacceptable
maintenant si vous voulez que je vous
dise que bien évidemment tous les
policiers qui sont décédés dans
l'exercice de leur de leur fonction bien
évidemment que je leur rends hommage
c'est une évidence mais je le fais pas
au coup de klaxon ou aux injonctions de
Monsieur Darmanin qui après nous avoir
craché dessus pendant plusieurs minutes
nous demande de nous lever parce qu'il
nous a demandé de le faire voilà c'est
pas monsieur Darmanin qui va
finir par la police
quand ils regardent les Français ils
sont suffisamment intelligents pour
pouvoir aller consulter par exemple
notre programme et les Français ils
sauront peut-être si vous aussi quand
Jean-Luc Mélenchon écrit la police tu
euh on va prendre les sujets on va
prendre les sujets si vous voulez bien
les uns après les autres d'abord si les
Français ils veulent savoir ce que nous
proposons sur la police je les invite à
consulter notre programme les Français
ils apprendront par exemple que nous
avons été le seul groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale à avoir proposé de mettre en
place une commission d'enquête sur le
suicide des policiers donc vous voyez
que les conditions de travail les
conditions de vie des policiers ça nous
intéresse que les Français ils
apprendront que on aime tellement pas
les policiers qu'on propose d'en
embaucher 10000 de plus donc peut-être
que ça ça les intéressera que les
Français ils comprendront que nous
proposons un certain nombre de réforme
en profondeur de la police que l'état de
délabrement dans lequel travaille un
certain nombre de policiers dans des
commissariats sont des sujets qui nous
intéressent beaucoup et que nous faisons
des propositions sur ce sujet donc il
faut arrêter quand on nous proposons de
réformer en profondeur la police c'est
pas parce que nous l'aimons pas c'est
justement parce qu'on considère qu'elle
doit être une police qui a une police
républicaine donc moi je voudrais qu'on
fasse un petit peu moins de
communication de politique politicienne
d'instrumentalisation et qu'on regarde
réellement les propositions des uns et
des autres pour le reste vous m'avez
interrogé sur ce sujet quand nous disons
que la police tue qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé il y a 15 jours avec la mort de ce
jeune homme Naël de 17 ans il a bien été
tué par un policier donc à un moment
est-ce que c'est la police mais madame
quand on interroge des effets de
structure quand on interroge des effets
de système on met pas en cause
l'ensemble des personnes qui travaillent
dans une institution si je vous dis
l'EHPAD maltraite je suis pas en train
de dire que l'ensemble des personnes qui
travaillent dans les EHPAD sont
responsables d'une maltraitance je dis
qu'il y a un système dans lequel il y a
pas suffisamment de moyens donc il y a
pas suffisamment d'encadrement et donc
ça peut générer des situations de
maltraitance donc je dis la même chose
sur la police je dis qu'il y a un
système organisé qui fait qu'il y a une
forme d'omerta que quand il y a une
violence policière comme ça a été le cas
il y a une quinzaine de jours 10 jours
un peu plus de 10 jours avec le décès de
ce jeune homme Naël il pas un mécanisme
de protection par l'institution
policière ça a été le cas vous le savez
puisque les premières informations
volontaire il est en détention
provisoire madame avant que il ait été
mis en détention provisoire la première
version de source policière comme vous
dites dans les médias elle ne disait pas
que le policier était devant le véhicule
et que donc il était en état de légitime
défense ici c'est ce qu'elle disait et
ce qui a permis de contredire cette
version c'est qu'il y a eu une vidéo
voilà ce qui s'est passé donc maintenant
parce que je veux bien qu'à chaque fois
on a posé la question des causes de ce
qui s'est passé après etc maintenant la
question que je pose c'est est-ce que
enfin on va s'attaquer à ce qui a généré
l'explosion à laquelle on a assisté ces
derniers jours quand on est intelligents
quand on est rationnel on regarde des
événements et on regarde la cause de ces
événements et on essaye de répondre à la
cause de ces événements la cause de ces
événements c'est un rapport dégradé
entre la police et une partie de la
population et c'est à ça qu'il faut
s'attaquer donc je mets sur la table des
propositions revenir sur la modification
de la loi de 2017 parce que depuis qu'il
y a eu une application en 2017 de la loi
sous Bernard Cazeneuve le nombre de
personnes qui sont décédées suite à des
contrôles de police ou à des refus
d'obtempérer a été multipliés par 5 donc
il faut revenir sur cette loi
deuxièmement il faut décider du
dépaysement systématique des enquêtes
liées à des violences policières pour
que ça soit pas les juges qui ont
l'habitude de travailler avec les
policiers mises en cause qui jugent ces
cas quand il y a un problème sur ce
sujet troisièmement je dis qu'il faut
mettre en place une réforme et une
remise à plat de l'IGPN pour que lui
soit substitué une autorité de contrôle
indépendante voilà des propositions qui
me paraissent être des propositions
rationnelles et enfin il faut s'attaquer
aux problèmes du racisme dans la police
et je suis stupéfait que quand l'ONU dit
il y a un problème de racisme dans la
police en France le gouvernement dise
non non circulé il y a rien à voir il y
a pas de problème il y a pas de problème
de racisme dans la police il y a 70% des
Français qui pensent qu'il y a un
problème de racisme dans la police donc
il faut s'attaquer à ce problème parce
que si on veut pas que les rapports
entre la population et la police soit
des rapports de tension mais des
rapports de confiance il faut répondre à
ces problématiques une difficulté vous
dites il y a une extrême droitisation de
la police aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez les enquêtes
électorales chez les policiers il y a de
plus en plus de policiers qui votent à
l'extrême droite mais à la limite ils
ont le droit
mais le problème est pas ça le problème
est ce qu'ils n'ont pas le droit c'est
de
le racisme c'est pas une opinion par
contre c'est un délit donc le racisme
dans la police c'est inacceptable et
donc j'attends de la fermeté sur ce
sujet et puisque vous m'interrogez sur
la police il y a aussi des choses
inacceptables par exemple quand à Lyon
et une ça police publie un communiqué
dans lequel ils insultent une partie de
la population les qualifiants de
nuisibles et quand ils menacent le
pouvoir politique là par exemple je vous
invite quand même à interroger le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est
incapable de dire que ce communiqué est
inacceptable il est incapable de
condamner clairement et faire un moment
se communiquer or je rappelle que la
police elle est pas en guerre contre une
partie de la population et que la police
elle défie pas et elle menace pas le
pouvoir politique elle est à son service
voilà elle est au service de la
population et elle est aux ordres du
pouvoir politique et le ministre de
l'Intérieur aurait dû sanctionner aurait
dû condamner clairement se communiquer
parce qu'il est inacceptable autre sujet
alors le chef de l'État lui fait tout à
fait la même analyse que vous des
événements qui sont déroulés en banlieue
durant ces 5 jours lui dit qu'il y a un
problème d'ordre et il veut sanctionner
les familles des enfants qui ont et des
adolescents qui ont participé aux
émeutes des Français semblent publicités
cette mesure pourquoi est-ce que vous
vous y opposez d'abord c'est pas un
problème de d'analyse parce que il y a
bien une cause à ce qui s'est passé et
cette cause c'est bien la mort de Naël
c'est ça qui a produit le reste donc je
le président de la République et cherche
de trouver cherche à trouver des
responsables partout sauf sur
l'événement qui a créé l'explosion donc
je trouve ça stupéfiant d'un point de
vue de logique intellectuelle donc pour
le président de la République c'est la
faute de tout le monde sauf de lui et
sauf de l'organisation de la police donc
c'est le problème des jeux vidéo c'est
le problème des réseaux sociaux c'est le
problème des parents et puis c'est le
problème de la France insoumise
globalement de tout le monde
maintenant sur la question des sur la
question des des parents je trouve audio
la manière avec laquelle le président de
la République cible comme ça du doigt
les parents parce que quand on est
parents en fait on fait du mieux qu'on
peut pour essayer d'éduquer ses enfants
on fait du mieux qu'on peut et des fois
on y arrive pas c'est vrai des fois les
parents font des bêtises mais vous savez
madame il y a pas que dans les
catégories populaires qu'il y a des
enfants qui font des bêtises parce que
si vous voulez je peux vous faire la
liste des responsables politiques y
compris au gouvernement qui ont eu des
problèmes avec leurs enfants récemment
et personne n'a eu l'intention d'aller
pointer leur propre responsabilités
parce que chacun fait du mieux qui peut
mais quand on vit par exemple dans la
cité Pablo Picasso à Nanterre que dans
cette cité Pablo Picasso à Nanterre il y
a 30% de famille qui sont monoparentales
que parmi ces 30% de famille qui sont
monoparentales il y en a 50% qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté quand vous
avez des mamans qui
trois métiers trois boulots trois petits
boulots pour essayer justement que leurs
enfants puissent avoir accès à une
éducation de qualité qui se lève à 5h du
matin bah oui ils sont pas là pour
emmener les enfants à l'école qui
travaille jusqu'à la nuit jusqu'à 22h
jusqu'à minuit bah oui ils sont pas là
pour aller chercher à l'école donc les
pointer du doigt comme ça je trouve ça
inacceptable je trouve ça audio quand
même c'est que un jeune sur deux n'était
pas accompagné lors de sa comparution
immédiate est-ce que c'est pas
questionnant quand même mais encore une
fois pourquoi pas parce que les parents
n'en ont rien à faire mais peut-être
parce qu'il ne pouvait pas donc je je
dis que c'est audio de pointer du doigt
la responsabilité des parents et je dis
que par ailleurs les mesures qui sont
mises sur la table sont
contre-productives parce que quand vous
allez prendre une famille dans lequel
vous allez avoir trois ou quatre enfants
et parce que un enfant a fait une bêtise
vous allez par exemple supprimer les
allocations familiales ça veut dire que
vous allez rétablir une punition
collective mais les trois enfants qui
font bien leurs devoirs qui sont allés à
l'école et pourquoi il devrait payer
pour les autres pour quelle raison
est-ce que ça va pas c'est une
proposition
elle s'inscrit dans la même logique elle
consiste à dire ce gouvernement c'est
une sanction c'est une amende sur un
c'est précis et pas une suppression des
allocations familiales alors c'est pas
ça c'est pareil bon d'abord d'un point
de vue légal ça tient pas la route tout
le monde le dit tous les juristes disent
que il y a un problème sur ce sujet mais
je voudrais vous dire aussi madame que
des mesures de de d'accompagnement par
exemple éducatif ça existe déjà les
juges pour enfants peuvent décider
parfois quand un enfant fait une bêtise
que il faut aider la famille à son
éducation et donc met en place des
mesures d'accompagnement éducative bon
vous savez le problème il y a eu une
tribune il y a deux ans des juges pour
enfants de Bobigny qui disent le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui par
parfois il faut 18 mois pour trouver un
éducateur ou une association qui peut
mettre en place cette mesure
d'accompagnement éducative donc je
trouve hypocrite et scandaleux ceux qui
viennent sur les plateaux de télévision
pour faire des grandes leçons sur le
sujet mais qui depuis des années des
années on s'abré les budgets pour les
éducateurs on sabrer les budgets pour
les associations parce que c'est bien
beau de venir dire on va faire ça on va
pointer du doigt etc mais les quand les
mesures qui existent déjà ne peuvent pas
être mises en place parce que les mêmes
ont réduit les moyens qui permettaient à
leur mise en place je pense que c'est
des hypocrites je pense que vous dites
mais pour vous il y a aucun par des
missionnaires c'est-à-dire que je
comprends la maman solo qui doit
travailler qui en cumule trois boulots
mais il y a pas que ce modèle là de
famille mais il peut comme partout il
peut oui y avoir parfois mais là la
manifestement ça vous dérange moins de
faire des effets de système là ça
dérange moins Emmanuel Macron dire le
problème c'est les parents là on me dit
pas c'est comme la police vous voyez
donc à un moment faut être un petit peu
cohérent je dis que quand il peut y
avoir des parents qui ont des
difficultés pour éduquer leurs enfants
ça peut exister il faut les aider faut
les accompagner faut pas les pointer du
doigt et les sanctionner et les aider
les accompagner c'est notamment ces
mesures d'accompagnement et d'assistance
éducative donc je dis qu'il faut plus de
moyens dans les associations qui s'en
occupent je dis qu'il faut plus
d'éducatrice et d'éducateurs dans les
quartiers populaires et pas les
supprimer comme ça a été fait depuis des
années des années ces émeutes elles ont
eu des conséquences dans les communes il
y a une loi d'urgence pour accélérer la
reconstruction qui va être examinée par
le Parlement la semaine prochaine est-ce
que vous la voterez ben ça je vais voir
ce qu'il y a dedans d'abord mais bien
sûr que s'il s'agit d'aider les
collectivités territoriale ou les
commerçants à pouvoir le plus rapidement
possible
réparer ce qui a été dégradé ou ce qui a
été cassé oui j'ai aucune raison de ne
pas soutenir mais si on veut parler de
réparation moi je voudrais qu'on parle
de réparation dans toutes ces dimensions
la réparation immédiate la réparation
urgente mais alors peut-être qu'on
pourra parler de la réparation de
manière plus générale par exemple de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des services
publics dans nos quartiers populaires
qui en ont de moins en moins ça c'est
une réparation aussi peut-être qu'on
pourra parler de l'état de délabrement
du logement social dans un certain
nombre de nos quartiers populaires parce
que contrairement aux bêtises que
j'entends depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant les quartiers populaires ne
sont pas gorgés d'argent public comme on
dit au contraire les quartiers
populaires et contribuent davantage que
les autres quartiers de France à la
solidarité nationale ils sont davantage
contributeurs que ce qu'il reçoit et
donc je voudrais que ceux qui viennent
sur les plateaux de télévision pour dire
on a donné déjà beaucoup d'argent au
quartier populaire etc ils disent les
chiffres ils disent pourquoi ils disent
sur la base de quoi ils peuvent dire des
inepies donc voilà si on parle de
réparation parlant de réparation dans
ces dimensions c'est quand même ce que
remonte les sondages c'est que les
Français disent on a consacré trop
d'argent au quartier populaire
aujourd'hui et pas assez au reste de la
France vous entendez ça et je sais pas
sur la base de quel sondage vous dites
ça parce que
j'ai vu un sondage la semaine dernière
qui disait que 70% à peu près des
Français considérés qu'il fallait un
plan d'urgence pour les quartiers
populaires donc ça veut dire que il
considérait pas qu'on avait mis trop
d'argent plutôt l'inverse il considéré
qu'il fallait faire plus que ce qu'on
avait fait pour l'instant quand on
ressenti vous savez moi j'ai arrêté de
faire de la politique sur la base des
ressentis j'essaye de le faire sur la
base des faits et j'aimerais que le
gouvernement le fasse aussi parce que je
suis quand même stupéfait que depuis 10
jours on parle de tout sauf de ce qui a
créé l'explosion tous les sujets sont
ouverts sauf un c'est celui du rapport
entre la police et la population et
pourquoi on peut pas parler de ce sujet
parce que Monsieur Darmanin a peur parce
que c'est la police qui décide à sa
place parce que c'est les syndicats de
police qui font la politique du
ministère de l'Intérieur aujourd'hui
parce que le seul qui a une fois
à 60 ans et que tôt ou tard je vous le
dis dans ce pays cette loi sur les
retraites elle sera abrogée parce
qu'elle n'est pas légitime qu'elle n'a
aucune légitimité cette loi donc oui
nous là nous là mangerons dès que nous
pourrons mais alors est-ce que les
syndicats ont raison aujourd'hui
d'accepter l'invitation et d'isabeth
borne essayer d'aller de l'avant sur
d'autres sujets vraiment l'augmentation
des salaires et notamment la future loi
travail écoutez d'abord moi je suis pas
responsable syndical donc j'ai j'ai pas
l'intention de décider de commenter ou
mais j'ai mon j'ai mon opinion mais les
organisations syndicales elles ont la
leur et je la respecte et et je je n'ai
pas l'intention de la de la critiquer
pour le reste il y a cette sujet
je ne sais pas comme je vous le dis je
ne suis pas responsable syndical donc
j'imagine qu'ils ont discuté entre eux
de quel était la meilleure démarche
c'est la meilleure manière de faire
maintenant là où je les comprends c'est
qu'il y a d'autres sujets qui sont sur
la table c'est vrai la question des
salaires est une question centrale tout
le monde sait que l'inflation est autour
de 6% cette année et que les
rémunérations elles ont augmenté entre
3, 5 et 4% donc en vérité depuis un an
les Français et les Français ont perdu
du pouvoir d'achat quand dans le même
temps vous avez par contre un certain
nombre de grandes puissances économiques
et de cette grande puissance financière
qui eux sont mis plein plein les poches
on dit l'inflation c'est à cause de la
guerre en Ukraine c'est à cause du covid
etc non l'inflation c'est à cause de
l'augmentation des marges de la grande
distribution et de l'industrie
agroalimentaire et j'observe que le
gouvernement Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
c'est Bruno demande hein je demande s'il
vous plaît faites un petit effort faites
un petit effort sur les salaires faire
un petit effort sur les prix mais il ne
fait rien il ne fait rien la vérité
c'est que c'est les Françaises et les
Français qui payent l'impact de
l'inflation par des augmentations de
salaires qui sont pas au niveau de
l'inflation par des explosions de prix
et que Madame borne plutôt que de dire
qu'elle est venue délivrée les
politiques comme je sais pas une
responsable d'entreprise elle devrait se
rappeler que dans ce pays il y a des
gens qui souffrent il y a des gens qui
ont faim il y a des gens qui galèrent et
on attend de sa politique elles
permettent enfin de répondre à ces
problèmes
pas il nous reste peu de temps on va
dire un mot des européennes les
écologistes sont officialisés leur tête
de liste est-ce que vous faites une
croix sur une liste commune à gauche non
je reste mon point de vue reste le même
au mon point de vue c'est que dans le
contexte actuel les élections
européennes devraient être la
démonstration que la nupesse est la
principale alternative au pouvoir en
place et que pour faire cette
démonstration je considère que la liste
commune de la lupesse est la meilleure
des options et la meilleure des des
solutions
il reste encore du temps avant
l'élection européenne à discuter avec
eux bah je le souhaite oui je
personnellement je j'adure mais
camarades de la nups de comprendre je
les adjure de comprendre que la liste
commune aux élections européennes est
une nécessité que 75% des sympathisants
de gauchissons favorables et qu'il faut
les écouter et que c'est pas les
militants ou les dirigeants de quelques
organisations qui peuvent décider comme
ça tout seul de détruire la nups que la
nuit pêche a été une force que ça a été
une chance et que moi j'y suis attaché
et que je considère que c'est une
opportunité pour être une alternative
dans ce pays et je mets en garde tous
celles et tous ceux qui voudraient
revenir à la gauche d'après c'est à dire
aux gauches irréconciliables revenir au
moment du hollandisme je les mets en
garde je leur ai dit vous faites une
erreur parce que la nups elle a ouverte
elle a ouvert un espoir une alternative
et que c'est irresponsable de prendre le
risque de la détruire
si vous n'avez pas de liste commune à
gauche pour les européennes ça détruit
la nuit pour vous bah c'est un risque
puisque je vois bien que aux élections
sénatoriales il y a eu une décision qui
a été de nous exclure de l'ensemble des
listes je vois bien qu'aux élections
européennes un certain nombre d'entre
eux veulent se compter individuellement
je vois bien que Monsieur Fabien Roussel
nous dit que la nups est dépassée c'est
le les propos qu'il a utilisé hier dans
la presse et je dis de mon point de vue
j'ai le droit de le penser que ces
différentes initiatives sont
irresponsables parce qu'elles mettent en
danger l'avenir de la nups et qu'on a
besoin de la nuclés
ne fonctionne plus très bien ou plus du
tout même à l'Assemblée nationale
mardi matin en réunion de l'Inter groupe
de laupes à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui dans
un groupe toutes les semaines depuis
notre élection c'est parce que disent
les vos partenaires en tous les cas les
déclarations de ça je vous promets je
pense que vous vous faites confusion
avec autre chose mais sur l'interdrome
de la nups à l'Assemblée nationale il se
réunit de chaque semaine depuis notre
élection en tous les cas les
déclarations de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur
concernant les émeutes on divisé au sein
de manifest est-ce que vraiment vous
souhaitez que la nuit pèse continue
ou est-ce que certains je veux dire le
problème si vous voulez c'est que à
chaque fois on essaye de venir faire
porter à Jean-Luc Mélenchon la
responsabilité de tel ou telle chose ce
qui a divisé parce qu'il y a eu
effectivement des sujets désaccords dans
la séquence qui vient de s'ouvrir c'est
pas les déclarations de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est que sur certains sujets
on a un désaccord Olivier Faure a voté
la loi de 2017 moi je suis pour son
abrogation donc oui on a un désaccord
sur ce sujet Fabien Roussel a participé
à la manifestation dont je parlais tout
à l'heure à l'appel d'alliance devant
l'Assemblée nationale vous vous rappelez
celle où les syndicats de police
disaient que le problème de la police
c'est la justice donc j'ai un désaccord
majeur avec Fabien Roussel sur ce sujet
donc on a des désaccords mais si on
pouvait arrêter dans la nups à chaque
fois qu'il y a un désaccord d'expliquer
que c'est la responsabilité de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de participe pas de l'Inter
groupe de la nupège je pense que ce
serait bien donc il faut dire les choses
franchement faut pas être hypocrite la
question qui est posée et qui est posée
à chacune des composantes de la nups
c'est ce que oui ou non vous voulez
continuer la nuit moi ma réponse elle
est claire c'est oui bah j'attends de
nos
la seule elle est assez claire aussi
c'est ça a l'air plutôt non alors qu'ils
prennent qu'il aille jusqu'au bout de sa
logique s'il pense que la nuit pêche est
dépassée s'il le pense alors il faut et
ben donc dans ce cas-là qu'il le fasse
voilà moi je suis pas d'accord avec ça
je pense que c'est une erreur une erreur
grave je pense que la nups ça a été une
vague d'enthousiasme d'espoir de pour
être une alternative au macronisme mais
à l'extrême droite voilà et je pense que
tous ceux qui dans cette situation là
prennent le risque de la fracturer de la
diviser prenne une très lourde
responsabilité devant l'histoire
d'organisation d'une primaire pour 2027
parce que c'est une bonne idée justement
pour rassembler tout le monde derrière
le 27 c'est loin mais si euh moi si je
suis attaché à la nupestre notamment
pour qu'il puisse avoir des candidatures
communes à chaque élection et une
candidature commune à l'élection
présidentielle et dans ce cas faudra un
mécanisme de départage il faudra un
mécanisme pour décider de notre candidat
certains proposent la primaire moi c'est
pas la forme qui a priori m'intéresse le
plus pour plein de raisons que j'ai pas
le temps de détailler ici mais oui il
faudrait bien un processus en tout cas
pour avoir une candidature commune mais
pour arriver en 2027 ensemble faut pas
être hypocrite pour arriver en 2027
ensemble il faut être ensemble aux
élections européennes il faut être
ensemble aux élections municipales parce
que ça vous ranger derrière les
écologistes européennes
j'ai déjà proposé j'ai déjà dit que la
question de la tête de liste ne devait
pas être un obstacle à la liste commune
enfin excusez-moi après j'ai compris
qu'on était pressé qu'est-ce que je peux
faire de plus qu'est-ce que je peux
faire de plus de vous dire je suis pour
une liste commune aux élections
européennes je pense que ça doit être la
clé s'il faut pour ça que ça soit les
écologistes qui l'amène je suis d'accord
il y a des élections municipales je suis
pour des listes communes aux élections
municipales s'il faut parfois être
derrière le maire sortant écologiste
socialiste je suis d'accord qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je fasse de plus que
ça bon maintenant si les autres veulent
pas mais juste qu'ils assument mais
qu'ils essayent pas de m'en faire porter
la responsabilité merci manuel merci à
vous merci beaucoup
c'est Naël des émeutes à 650 millions
cette Emmanuel bonne journée invité on
passe au club des territoires